that's why I'm running for re-election
because I know America
President Joe Biden has launched his
re-election campaign for 2024 a move
that has long been expected
Joe Biden is going to be running for
president at a time when there's divided
government he will have House
Republicans to serve as a foil for his
agenda so what's changed for Biden since
2020 and what challenges will he face
this time President Biden's re-election
campaign is likely to focus on his
record of getting things through the
Congress like the infrastructure law a
climate package
as well as just getting the country
through the pandemic but those wins came
when Democrats controlled both chambers
of Congress before Republicans took the
house after the midterm elections last
year Joe Biden will often say on the
campaign Trail in the months ahead that
there are more things that I want to get
done I want to finish the job but there
are House Republicans who are standing
in the way Biden's team has argued that
his legislative wins will resonate with
voters in the election but his approval
ratings paint a different picture just
over 42 percent of Voters approve of his
handling of the presidency compared to
nearly 53 percent who disapprove
according to a poll conducted by the
website 538 there's a lot of questions
and concerns and frustration frankly
about the level of inflation that
Americans have had to deal with the last
few years there's this concern about
Americans not being able to get ahead in
this aftermath of the pandemic
Republicans have routinely blamed Rising
costs and inflation on guidance stimulus
packages like the American Rescue plan
and the bipartisan infrastructure law
the same ones Biden touts as legislative
wins now we're creating jobs we're
exporting jobs no longer American
products are being made here we're
growing the economy another obstacle
President Biden faces is his age at the
age of 80 Biden is already the oldest
president in American history if he wins
a second term he will leave the White
House at age 86. that has drawn a lot of
questions about whether he would have
the physical stamina to do the job
whether a vote for President Biden might
actually be a vote for vice president
Kamala Harris
the president is largely considered a
front-runner in the 2024 election
without a serious Democratic primary
Challenger
but on the other side of the aisle Biden
is preparing to face off again with his
2020 opponent Donald Trump the former
president announced his bid for 2024
last November America's comeback starts
right now
Democrats do not underestimate the power
of former president Donald Trump but
they feel like there are some strategic
benefits to a match-up with Trump the
former president has been dealing with
these legal issues that we may see more
of it later in the summer they know that
this is someone that they've defeated
before now that Biden has officially
entered the race he can focus his
re-election campaign on fundraising and
Staffing the White House is going to try
to spin this campaign as a choice not as
a referendum on his first term but
simply a choice with whoever the
Republicans decide to nominate he's
going to argue that in that matchup he
can offer more to the country than the
Republican candidate